So.
Weiter geht's.
Oh, der Sound funzt heute gleich mal.
First try.
Huge Windows.
Oh, ein Zuschauer ist schon da.
Ob das der Feuer ist?
Post Champ.
Mal gucken.
Mein Handy macht Geräusche.
Moment, warum macht das so?
Ah, weil ich es nicht gemutet habe.
Ich mute mich mal.
So.
Ha, da ist er.
Hast du gehört, dass ich dich erwähnt habe, bevor du da warst?
Ich habe gesagt, einen Zuschauer sehe ich gerade auf Twitch, ob das der Feu da ist.
Aber das war noch zu früh, da warst du noch nicht da.
Hey Leute, schön, dass ihr am Start seid.
Heute geht es weiter mit Quarkus.
Wer gestern nicht dabei war, der hat by the way nichts verpasst.
Weil das, was wir bisher gemacht haben, ist sehr übersichtlich.
Das hat man sich in zwei Minuten angeguckt.
Aber wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich mach mal Updates
Nicht, dass es wieder 3 Stunden dauert
Das war ja gestern
Grausam
Und wir müssen gucken, ob Copy-Paste
Aus der VM wieder funktioniert
Das Schreiben von gestern
Ist nicht mehr online
Nee, nee, ich hab wieder Zeug geleakt
Aber wie gesagt, du hast nichts verpasst
Das ist in
Zwei Minuten
Einer Minute hat man alles gesehen
Was wir gestern hingekriegt haben
Und zwar nicht
Dass es irgendwie easy war
Es herauszukriegen, aber von der Menge her
Ist es total
Super schnell sich angeguckt
Dachte du bist in
Was?
Ich war heute in Frankfurt.
All you can eat, Sushi futtern.
Gucken, ob es die Seite noch gibt.
Nitter.
guck
was ich heute Sushi-Stelz
futtern
ähm
die Dinger waren richtig nice
das ist eher so 0815 Zeug
ähm, die richtig guten Sachen sind hier gar nicht
drauf, hier unten ist ein bisschen frittierter
Kram drauf, aber echt pock
die Preise könnt ihr vergessen hier oben
pro Teller
ich habe alle kennedige futtert und ich
habe an die 30 teller gegessen also
solche kleinen teller so also wirklich
ich würde sagen so an an die 30 also
25 mindestens weil die waren dreimal bei
mir abräumen und am ende hatte ich
immer noch sachen stehen
Und all you can eat ist halt das nice.
Du musst nicht drauf gucken, welcher Teller wie teuer ist und sowas.
Kannst einfach reinfressen.
Pepo-Fett kannst du machen.
Richtig Pepo-Fett.
Ist aber teuer.
All you can eat.
Oder ratet mal, Leute.
Was mittlerweile all you can eat Sushi kostet hier in Frankfurt.
Bei dem Laden.
30 Euro gar nicht so schlecht gar nicht so schlecht geraten ist aber nicht ganz richtig ist aber geht aber in die Richtung
Also das ist wirklich also vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich das noch nicht bezahlt. Es kostet 36 Euro
pro Person
36 Euro
Deswegen musste ich auch so viel fressen sonst hätte ich das nicht gelohnt
ich muss diese ich muss die 36 euro irgendwie futtern ich hatte eigentlich
haben schon ein bisschen schritt geguckt weil ich so viel gefressen aber hey mit
36 euro kostet da musst du musst du durch also diese dinge die waren echt
das ist mit vierte garnelen ich glaube avocado und dann halt reis und dieses wie heißt das da
dieses zeug zum umwickeln da dieses reis dieses papier zeug da und dann nicht so ist noch drüber
also deshalb wirklich gut geschmeckt und auch das kind sie hat gut schmeckt insgesamt muss
ist erlangen verkehrt gewesen übrigens die beste antwort auf mein
tweet fast 30 fast 30 teller gegessen und er antwortet aber davon muss man
nicht aufs klo mal gut schreibt habe die woche eine zusage putt das ist nice
arbeit ab nächster woche auch in der it bei einer bank hätte nicht gedacht dass
es so schnell klappt auch in frankfurt oder wo bist du 14 euro bei mcdonald's
kostet mittlerweile müsste man vorstellen das ganz normale menü also
so einen ekliger McDonalds Burger
mit labberigem Pommes Frites
und Cola.
Ich glaube sogar einen kleinen nur.
Dieses Standardmenü kostet mittlerweile
14 Euro.
So 13,80 oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist total gestört.
Überlegt euch das mal.
Letztes Mal, wo ich da war,
hat es noch unter 10 Euro gekostet.
Aber bei McDonalds war ich auch schon eine ganze Weile.
Wenn ich überlege,
als ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
ne?
Achso, übrigens, ich gebe zu,
die Zeit des Streams ist wahrscheinlich
heute auch wieder relativ ungünstig.
Noch etwas ungünstiger als gestern.
Gestern habe ich immerhin noch zu Zeiten
gestreamt, wo die Leute auf der Arbeit zugucken
konnten nebenbei oder im Homeoffice.
Jetzt sind die Leute fertig arbeiten
und jetzt ist eigentlich gar keiner da.
Das ist, glaube ich, die schlechteste Zeit
zu streben überhaupt jetzt.
Aber das macht nichts.
Umso schöner, dass Leute, dass ihr hier am Start seid.
Das wollte ich nicht sagen.
Ja, also in meiner Zeit, wo ich
noch meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, also
ist schon eine ganze Weile her, ne?
Ach, guck mal. Die Container laufen
hier noch.
Da war ich so oft
bei McDonalds und Burger King, das war schon nicht
mehr gesund. Aber damals gab es
auch gefühlt jede woche gutscheine und die hatten damals diesen chili cheese
burger neue bei burger king und den gab es auch mit gutschein und so was habe
ich richtig gerne gegessen damals
mittlerweile ich war jahre nicht mal bei mcdonalds und burger king jetzt
ungelogen also es richtig lang her letztens wieder aus wie hat habe ich
einige zugemacht ich präse mich freut das immer hier waren schon öfters leute im stream die gesagt
habe ich habe sie darauf gebracht das zu machen und das war die richtige entscheidung und so
also da haben wenigstens meine videos irgendwas bewirkt ja so bekommt man eigentlich in einer
kurs ein größeres gehalt als auf dem land potenziell würde ich sagen ist das so
ja potenziell bekommst du da mehr geld
und am besten noch wenn es eine großstadt ist mit versicherung und
banken weil die bezahlen auch gut ich glaube ich glaube banken ist auf platz
eins vom gehalt gefolgt von versicherung gefolgt von pharma oder auto ich bin
mir jetzt immer ganz sicher was auf drei war aber aber finanzbranche bezahlt am
besten
bei der bader bank habe ich habe ich ein konto aber jetzt gezwungenermaßen weil
ich bei scalable bin und scalable kooperiert mit der bada bank bis vor 14 tagen da wurde
alles umgestellt auf nicht mehr badebank bekommt man in der industrie was passt was verstehst du
und der Industrie.
So was.
Metallherstellung oder
Ja, schön, dass du
am Start bist.
Also es gab letztens
ich weiß nicht mehr wo.
Ich habe
keine Ahnung wo das war.
Welche Branchen im Durchschnitt
das beste Gehalt bezahlen?
Da war Bank auf 1 und Versicherung
auf 2.
Und dann weiß ich nicht, ob es Automobilindustrie oder Pharma-Zeug irgendwie auf Platz 3 waren.
Wo ich mir jetzt auch nicht sicher bin, ist, ob das nicht nur IT-Jobs waren.
Aber ich glaube, das war insgesamt...
Malgo, lass dir vom Chat nicht deine Ausbildungssache schlecht reden.
Nur weil irgendwie einer mal da komisches Zeug fabriziert hat,
heißt nicht, dass die Ausbildung schlecht sein muss.
Außerdem weiß ich gar nicht, ob die komisches Zeug fabriziert haben.
Ich kann dazu gar nichts sagen.
In was hast du investiert?
das ist langweilig. Ich hab nur
ETF. Ich hab zwei Sachen.
Ich hab, Moment, wo hab ich
mein Handy?
Handy ist weg.
Okay.
Dann, dann sag ich's euch aus dem Kopf.
Ich hab zwei Sachen. Ich hab
ein World ETF
und dann
noch so Art Tagesgeld,
Euro, Euro
Swap oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist im Prinzip das, was die EZB auch als Leitzins angibt.
Kriegste da.
Das ist so für Kurzzeitsachen ganz gut.
Und ansonsten...
Hab ich nix?
Ich hatte mal so kleinen Scheiß.
Ich hatte mal AMD.
Ähm, hatte ich noch?
Also da hatte ich aber immer nicht viel davon.
Aber wobei.
Doch AMD hatte ich tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr gekauft damals.
Was waren das andere?
Ich hatte doch mal von einer Sache,
das habe ich sogar glaube ich im Stream erzählt,
ich hatte mal von einer Sache
so just for fun eine Aktie gekauft.
Ich weiß nicht.
Egal.
Aber
die einzigen Sachen, wo ich regelmäßig
einzahle, ist mein World ETF.
früher bei der bank wurde media kurz bald tja und jetzt als heute bin ich software dienstleister
bude muss fast traum battle das man ja ich war das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den laden wo
ich meine ausbildung gemacht habe das war ein internet provider das also internet provider
Schrägstrich auch Dienstleister
Bastelbude.
Also keiner der großen Bekannten.
da war es auch so.
Da gibt es eine Story.
Mein ehemaliger Chef von damals,
den haben sie
auf eine Fortbildung geschickt.
Irgendwo nach,
keine Ahnung, ich sage jetzt einfach mal München, weil
irgendjemand München geschrieben hat im Chat letztens.
Irgendwo von Frankfurt nach München geschickt.
Und
oder ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher überhaupt ob es eine fortbildung war oder dass er da
irgendwas machen musste sie haben ihn zumindest nach münchen geschickt ja so und er ist dann da
irgendwann keine ahnung abends um 20 uhr angekommen weil er sich geklappt hat auf dem weg und da hat
er sich, weil es schon so spät war,
hat er sich einen
Orangensaft im Hotel
geholt.
Für, keine Ahnung, 2,50 Euro
oder so.
Und da haben die danach
gesagt, nee, den Orangensaft bezahlen
wir dir nicht, 2,50 Euro.
Das wäre ja
nicht abgemacht gewesen oder sowas.
2,50 Euro, Alter!
Da ist
das Diskutieren teurer.
das diskutieren ist doch ganz ehrlich wenn einer sagt ich habe zwei euro vor also wenn ich der chef
wäre und es kommt zu mir einer sagt max ich habe 250 ausgekriegt ersetzt ich hätte die ich hätte
ihm wahrscheinlich schon vorher das befördert überhaupt angefangen hat zehn euro in die hand
gedrückt hat okay passt ja macht jede zeit mit der wir uns hier auseinandersetzen ist teurer
als das, worüber wir diskutieren.
Das war aber eh ein Scheißladen,
im Nachhinein betrachtet, wo ich da gewesen bin.
Da hab ich ja mal, da hab ich ja mal so,
da hab ich ja mal sogar ein Video drüber gemacht.
Nicht deshalb werde ich kündigen,
ich hab da ein Video zu gemacht, wo ich erzählt hab,
wenn der Chef dich verarscht,
das Video meine ich hier.
warum ich meinen job grün ist ja wenn der chef dich verarscht hier das video da habe ich darüber
erzählt wie das eben in dem laden wo ich die ausbildung gemacht habe danach bin ich ja noch
da geblieben wie das tag gelaufen ist und was für dinger alle die getrieben haben auch dieses
komische schulungsprogramm und so was ich muss ich will es jetzt gar nicht wieder aufwärmen wenn sie
interessiert, guckt euch einfach mal das Video an.
Es ist echt...
echt Haarstreuen, was da gelaufen ist.
Da gibt es noch...
Okay, eine Sache kann ich noch von dem Laden erzählen.
Nur, dass ihr mal wisst,
wie die
Geschäftsleitung da so drauf gewesen ist.
Die waren ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
und zwar
hier nochmal Update
und zwar gab es da so ein Gespräch
mit dem Chef
und zwar also
ich meine so Gespräche
wo versucht wird die Mitarbeiter
so auf wir sind die geilsten
und besten und
alle ganz toll einzuschwören
die gibt es ja überall
aber das war da nochmal was ganz besonderes
da gab es ein Gespräch mit dem Chef
also one on one
so und das ging dann sinngemäß so
gucken, dass ich jetzt
kein Mist erzähle, dass ich das halbwegs
korrekt wiedergebe
das ging dann so, also erstmal
erzähle, beste Firma, tollste
und überhaupt
und ob man das auch so sieht und
beste und so, also im Prinzip
super krass selbst gelobt
und
bespeichelt quasi
und dann hat er erzählt
der Chef, also
er würde ja auch von seinen Mitarbeitern
erwarten,
wenn er Bauer ist,
jetzt ganz abgedrehtes Zeug,
wenn er Bauer ist
und man würde bei ihm auf dem Feld
arbeiten. Also wenn es
allein schon so losgeht, ja,
dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
Also wenn er Bauer wäre
und man würde bei ihm auf dem
Feld arbeiten
und man sieht zufälligerweise,
dass der Acker
nebendran brach liegt.
dann erwartet er dass man ihm
das sagt
dass er dann damit
was anfangen kann oder so so was hat er sinngemäß erzählt
und das war eines der das war eines der momente wo ich auch gesagt habe okay leute es wird echt zeit für kek bei in dem laden
Ich weiß auch nicht was mit den leuten los ist ich weiß ich weiß noch nicht mal was er mir damit sagen wollte ehrlich gesagt
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der wollte.
Also, da wurde...
Der hat ganz merkwürdige Dinger erzählt,
der Kerl.
Und ja, wie gesagt, dann habe ich gedacht,
es ist Zeit für Kegbye.
Gab es ein Kernel-Update?
Wenn ja, müssen wir
rebooten.
Aber ich glaube, wir müssen nicht rebooten, ne?
Kein Kernel-Update, sieht nicht so aus.
Sehr gut.
Aber Rust.
Rust wurde aktualisiert.
Brauchen wir aber gar nicht.
Lul.
Ja, so kleiner Schwank aus der Ausbildung noch.
Aber der Kerl hat echt ganz merkwürdigen Kram erzählt.
Auf der anderen Seite bin ich doch froh, dass ich die Ausbildung dort gemacht habe.
Ich wurde ja nicht wirklich klassisch ausgebildet, wie man das kennt, dass es da irgendwie einen Plan gibt, was mit den Azubis passiert.
Nee, man hat einfach von Anfang an da mitgemacht und spätestens ab dem zweiten Jahr genug Sachen erledigt, die auch fertig ausgelernte, vollbezahlte Leute erledigt haben.
Also eine Sache, was ich damals halt auch cool in der Ausbildung fand, war, dass man so auf dem Rechenzentrum ist.
Ist ja immer noch so ein bisschen was, was ich vermisse, dass ich so gut wie nie im Rechenzentrum bin aktuell.
Ich darf ja noch nicht mal alleine rein
überhaupt ins Rechenzentrum mittlerweile.
Beim neuen Arbeitgeber.
Ich hab gar keinen Zugang. Da muss immer einer mitkommen
von der Security da und sowas.
Also, das vermisse ich ein bisschen.
Ich würde gerne... Also, Chat, wenn
einer bei euch in Frankfurt
jemand braucht, der mal ab und zu
ins Rechenzentrum
guckt und Festplatten austauscht,
dann sagt Bescheid, ja?
ja, keine blinkenden Lichter mehr anschauen.
Ja, ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt,
ich bin immer im Dunkeln durchs
Rechenzentrum gelaufen und gerade
zur Weihnachtszeit könnt ihr euch nicht
vorstellen, wie
was für eine weihnachtliche
Stimmung ein dunkles Rechenzentrum
ist. Das hat wirklich was von Weihnachtsbeleuchtung.
Überall blinkt
was grün und blau und orange.
das ist nice also ich bin immer gerne ins rechenzentrum gegangen ich muss mein
home lab ausbauen aber so krass kann ich das nicht ausbauen weil mein raum ist ja
quasi schon ausgelastet meine mini rack und da blinkt gar nicht so viel das
einzige was ein bisschen blinkt ist der switch der rest bringt nicht
Also das bringt daheim nichts.
Also ein echtes Rechenzentrum kann man da nicht toppen.
Lüfter rauschen im Hintergrund, ja.
Also das hatte ich noch nie, dass es überall rot blinkt.
Also meistens blinkt es orange, wenn es kaputt ist.
wenn irgendwie eine SSD ausgefallen ist
oder eine Festplatte ausgefallen ist, so ein Lüfter
oder so, da blinkt es meistens orange. Oder
bei den IBM-Kisten
gab es teilweise noch,
da hat es ein LED geleuchtet,
da konntest du vorne so ein Panel rausziehen
und da stand es dann noch ein bisschen
genauer drauf.
Also,
ja, aber Rechenzentrum war schon nice.
Also deswegen muss ich im Nachhinein sagen, die Ausbildung an sich war echt nicht schlecht.
Muss man mal sagen.
Es gab keine klassische Ausbildung von, man hat einen Plan, aber man hat halt einfach viel gemacht.
Und hat dementsprechend was gelernt.
Aber in der Ausbildung konntest du halt auch genauso gut nichts lernen.
Wenn du dich nicht dafür interessiert hast, hättest du bei dem Betrieb in der Ausbildung auch null Komma, also gar nichts lernen können.
Das hätte auch keinen interessiert.
Aber trotzdem muss ich sagen, im Nachhinein war ich ganz froh, dass ich da die Ausbildung gemacht habe, auch wenn sich der Laden als ziemlich kacke rausgestellt hat danach.
Aber die Ausbildung hatte ich in der Tasche und danach war ich ja auch noch kurz da, also schlecht war das nicht.
Und es hat dazu geführt, also nicht nur, dass ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe, sondern auch, dass ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Und was gelernt habe in der Ausbildung.
also viel von dem
was mich heute auch interessiert
mit Linux und
Hardware
ein bisschen Programmieren
und so
also vieles hat da angefangen
in der Ausbildung 2005
und
deswegen bin ich froh
dass ich das gemacht habe
und auf der anderen Seite
was das auch gebracht hat ist
wahrscheinlich hätte ich ohne die Ausbildung
dort
nicht den Job in der Bank gekriegt
und wäre jetzt nicht bei meinem Job in der Versicherung dadurch gelandet.
Also auch wenn der Ausbildungsbetrieb
letztendlich sich als Kackler herausgestellt hat,
war es aber doch, ohne dass man es damals wissen konnte,
für die Zukunft nicht schlecht.
Ja, jetzt sind wir ein bisschen side-getrackt worden.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich ordentlich geupdatet?
Ja, ich habe alles geupdatet. Update hier.
Update.
Update da.
IntelliJ läuft noch.
SSH läuft auch noch.
Ja, gut.
Ja, dann können wir weitermachen.
Wo sind wir dann stehen geblieben?
also ich zeige euch mal was wir gestern auf die reihe gekriegt haben das kann dazu sagen es ist
nicht viel was wir auf die reihe gekriegt haben wir haben gestern eine quarkus anwendung erstellt
das ist so ein java framework alternative zu spring boot wir haben geguckt wie man den
Start ist der Index HTML.
Ausliefert, are you still working as DevOps?
Yes.
But now it's not called DevOps anymore.
DevOps, it was called DevOps on my last job.
In my new job, I'm a Linux system engineer, I think.
Aber das ist zu altgeschrieben.
Es wird alle wieder genannt.
Und jetzt wird es, ähm,
Ich denke, starten wir nächstes Jahr.
Es wird Seite-Verwaltung-Ingenieur.
Warum?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Weil es mehr
Hype und moderne ist.
Aber es ist im Grunde das gleiche als der letzte Job.
High Performance Engineer.
Das Grindset Mindset läuft, Leute.
so also ich zeige jetzt mal kurz was wir gemacht haben für alle die gestern nicht
dabei waren also wir haben geguckt wie man mit quarkus eine index html seite
ausliefert und zwar so
ist meine musik gerade abgekackt
youtube geht mir teilweise echt heftig auf den keks aber 28 minuten warmer
YouTube ist so nervig seit ich was gegen Adblocker haben
Ich habe ja YouTube Premium sogar
So ist es ja gar nicht. Ich bezahle ja YouTube Premium und trotzdem muss ich mich hier mit Werbung rumschlagen
Okay, da kann, das weiß YouTube nicht, ich bin ja nicht eingeloggt, aber es fuckt mich trotzdem ab
Also dann sollen die mich doch, da sollen die doch wenigstens
Ich weiß, dass ich nicht eingeloggt bin
dann sollen wir doch wenigstens erlauben
ja, dass ich Adblocker
verwenden darf, ich bezahl doch schon YouTube Premium
ich bezahl mittlerweile sogar YouTube Premium
normal, 16
fucking Euro
ich mach
das nicht mehr über meinen
ähm
indischen Account
Also ich hab ab und zu mal Join benutzt.
Join ist ja quasi die App von ProSiebenSat1.
Weiß nicht, ob RTL da auch am Start ist.
Und da kriegst du alle Viertelstunde,
kriegst du länger als 1,30 Werbung.
Da kriegst du teilweise 4 Minuten Werbung oder so.
Deswegen benutze ich das auch nicht oft.
generell ich bin total allergisch gegen werbung wirklich immer anfälle die
werbung ist teilweise auch so unglaublich dumm was mich ja am meisten
triggert dass das überall jetzt irgendwann youtube influenza leute
rumspringen
letztendlich ist mir aber wurscht ja früher war es keine ahnung michael
schumacher oder so der werbung gemacht hat heute ist es gibt es da so keine
ahnung welche youtube influencers die ich nicht gucke
Bibi, gibt es Bibi überhaupt noch?
Nee, oder?
Die ist doch outdated, overrated.
She baited.
Oder die ganzen Influencers,
die nach Dubai ausgewandert sind.
Oh, ich habe gelesen,
Simon Desue wurde verhaftet
wegen Drogenbesitz in Dubai.
Das kann echt schnell in die Hose gehen.
Verstehen die keinen Spaß?
Da geht's zur Sache.
Welchen Raspberry Pi würdest du für ein Pi-Hole empfehlen?
Tja.
Die Dinger sind so teuer geworden.
Ich kann eigentlich gar keinen Raspberry Pi mehr so wirklich empfehlen.
Weil Raspberry Pi heißt ja nicht nur Raspberry Pi.
Raspberry Pi heißt Raspberry Pi.
eine SSD oder eine Mikro-SD, SSD ist eigentlich besser, dementsprechend ein gescheites Gehäuse und ein Netzteil.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich bin aktuell so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, ob sich Raspberry Pis zur Zeit überhaupt lohnen.
Das Einzige, wo ich es für verstehe, ist für Sachen, die nur auf einem Raspberry Pi gehen.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du die GPIO-Pins brauchst.
Also wenn du ein vollwertiges Linux und GPIO-Pins brauchst, dann ist der Raspberry Pi immer noch der Beste.
Nicht, dass es da nicht Alternativen gibt, aber vom Ökosystem her ist der Raspberry Pi einfach der Beste.
Also dann würde ich den kaufen.
Aber ansonsten, ich kann ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, ob sich Raspberry Pis so richtig lohnen.
Aber zumindest kannst du Piehole auf jeder Crapkiste laufen lassen.
Also auch auf dem älteren Raspberry Pi.
Wenn du günstig irgendwie einen...
Gibt es 3er noch?
4er auf jeden Fall.
Das ist also...
Das DNS Zeug braucht nicht viel.
Erwarte aber nicht so viel von einem Piehole.
Das blockt so gut wie nichts mehr.
Von den richtig nervigen Sachen
Die GPIOs sind auch seit dem Raspberry Pi 4
Nicht mehr richtig verwendbar
Warum nicht?
Es gibt immer noch ein riesen Ökosystem
Aus
Extension Sachen
Und
Header und sonst was
Warum sollten die nicht mehr richtig verwendbar sein?
Ich habe sogar selbst ein Raspberry Pi 4 im Keller stehen mit so einem Headerboard drauf über die GPIO-Sonst.
edgar at home habe ich mir auch angeguckt das ist aber schon ein paar jahre her da
habe ich mal verglichen so für mich bei holen und edgar at home und da muss ich
sagen hat mir edgar at home besser gefallen aber ich weiß nicht wie das heute ist
Genau, so ist es.
Das machen viele Seiten mittlerweile.
Werbung selbst aus.
Also quasi Content und Werbung von den gleichen Servern ausliefern.
So dass du nicht mehr blocken kannst.
Tja.
Ist das ein Proxy, der dazwischen ist?
Oder geht das nur über
DNS-Blocking? Weil das ist, dass
du in, also dann würden die
sich aber echt blöd anstellen, wenn die Werbung
so einfach blocken lassen.
Ich meine, das soll mir ja recht sein.
Ich will jetzt ja nicht beschweren,
dass Werbung da geblockt werden kann.
Ist ja gut.
Genau, das ist Funst.
Browser-Addons funktionieren ganz gut.
Aber rein mit DNS-Blocken kommt man halt nicht weiter.
Ja, es ist nicht verkehrt, sowas zu benutzen. Ich sag nur, man darf sich jetzt nicht zu viel davon erwarten.
so also ich zeige euch jetzt mal was wir gestern im stream gemacht haben für alle
die nicht dabei waren ich kann euch sagen das ist nicht viel
das immer haben wir in einer minute durch wir haben es geschafft eine index
html auszuliefern die by the way ich starte das mal die index html die macht
nichts außer
ausliefern also eine statische index html ausliefern mit mit quarkus dann haben wir
uns angeguckt wie man im hintergrund background jobs anlegen kann die machen aber aktuell nix
da läuft im background job einmal in der sekunde der im prinzip nichts macht dann haben wir uns
angeschaut wie wir konfiguration in die anwendung rein kriegen und das größte
was wir gestern gemacht haben ist das hier websocket verbindungen und zwar
gibt es auf dem endpunkt slash ws kann man sich verbinden mit einem websocket
client und bekommt dann einmal in der sekunde per websocket was geschickt
guck das kommt man einmal in der sekunde bekommt man eine sekunde geschickt das ist alles wir haben
nicht gemacht das funktioniert über quarkus messaging sprich hier aus diesem background
threat backgrounds worker background schedule ding wie auch immer das ding dabei quarkus heißt
keine ahnung schedule task heißt es glaube ich läuft alle sekunde und schiebt über so
einen internen message pass hier eine message rüber die der websocket händler sich schnappt
und dann alle offenen websocket verbindungen schickt das ist alles mehr haben wir nicht
gemacht gestern und heute mal weiter wo wir das bisschen aus so dass wir am ende ein bisschen mehr
Ahnung von Quarkus haben.
Springboot haben wir im Stream auch schon gemacht.
Bis jetzt muss ich sagen,
nicht viel Unterschied dazwischen.
Er kommt mit
beidem super klar. Auch als
jemand wie ich, der nicht so groß Ahnung
von Java hat.
Updates haben wir gestern gemacht. Ja, jede Menge
Updates. Lama Updates.
Wie kam es zu Java? Ja gut.
Warum ich Java ein bisschen
gelernt habe, also angefangen habe
zu lernen, vor einem
Monat oder so oder zwei,
ist, weil ich mache nächstes Jahr ein Java-Entwickler-Praktikum bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Ist nicht wirklich ein Praktikum, heißt nur so.
Ich gehe mal zwei, drei Wochen in eines unserer Entwicklerteams und gucke mir das da an.
Ich will nicht wechseln oder so, sage ich gleich.
Ich will mir das einfach ein bisschen angucken.
Und da hat auch schon einer gesagt, der will mal zu uns auch rüberkommen gucken.
Und dass ich überhaupt so ein bisschen Ahnung habe von dem, was die da machen,
habe ich mir gedacht, gucke ich mir im Vorfeld mal etwas Java an.
Oder Java, wie es die coolen Leute aussprechen.
Keck-Business-Anwendungen bauen?
Moment, haben wir kein Keck-Business-Emote mehr?
Moment!
Wo ist kek?
Ach, hier.
Keckrate Business.
Ich hab schon gedacht,
dass die Mode ist weg.
Äh, by the way,
kann es sein, dass mein Chat das nicht checkt?
Guck mal hier.
Aber...
aber der chat hier unten hat es nicht kapiert seit wann kann der keine schalten emotes wie
viele java entwickler hassen java was schätzt ihr ehrlich gesagt glaube ich
gar nicht so viele also unsere java entwickler auf der arbeit sind ziemliche java fans
ich glaube die meisten java entwickler finden java nice bei denen ist vielleicht eher die
frage java oder kotlin aber ich glaube die meisten java entwickler stehen voll auf dieses ökosystem
system
max weißt du was ich heute gesehen habe unser senior network engineer gut da
muss es wissen hat beim einstecken des glasfaserkabels sende und empfangs
richtung vertauscht und er war der überzeugung hat schon immer funktioniert
hast du auch so schlaue kollegen habe ich nicht wie schafft man das eigentlich
habt ihr die habt ihr die faser selbst in den in denen was sind das lc oder sc
stecker die kleinen meine ich wie kann man da überhaupt irgendwas vertauschen
die gehen und in eine richtung rum rein also es sei denn ihr habt die kabel
selbst in die Stecker gemacht.
Dann kann man es vertauschen.
Weil aber ansonsten passt
es ja alles nur in eine Richtung rein.
Java 7 und 8 waren
Pains Champ. Also
ich habe ja
gar keine Ahnung von Java gehabt, bis vor 1-2
Monaten.
Und das, also
dementsprechend kenne ich die alten
Java-Versionen nicht. Aber ich muss sagen,
das, was ich jetzt gesehen habe von Java,
fand ich nicht schlecht. Also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die finde ich in C-Sharp deutlich besser.
Beispielsweise, dass es Async Await gibt. Aber ansonsten sind es viele Parallelen, muss man sagen. Also die
Record Classes oder wie man diese Dinger, Records
Tracks, Record Types, wie man sie in Java nennt, ist sehr ähnlich zu dem, was wir in C-Sharp gemacht haben.
Dieses Stream-API bei
Arrays ist sehr ähnlich zu Link. Also
es hat schon große Überschneidungen
zu C Sharp.
Dementsprechend finde ich,
die haben sich auch die guten Sachen rausgepickt.
Was ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist,
sind die
100.000 Annotations.
Wobei man da sagen muss,
oder der Fan das halber sagen muss,
das ist jetzt nicht wirklich Java,
sondern das ist er halt die framework geschichte hier dass sie alles annotaten musste verrückt
ist auch alles annotated ich verstehe nicht so genau ehrlich gesagt warum das annotations sein
müssen warum das keine interfaces sein können oder base klassen wo was überschreiben kann oder so
oder interface interface das klingt eigentlich sinnvoll ja warum man nicht einfach ein inter
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich Java-Philosophie.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich habe absolut keinen
plassen Schimmer,
wie die Stecker dazu aussehen.
Achso, LC.
LC waren noch die kleinen Stecker.
Die da.
Da kann man doch gar nicht so viel verkehrt machen, oder?
Geh doch nur in eine Richtung rein.
Oder habt ihr die Kabel selbst dran gestöpselt?
Hier hinten
Ansonsten finde ich Java aber
Nicht schlecht
Muss ich sagen, also man kommt damit klar
Macht damit auch Spaß, was zu bauen
Performance, keine Ahnung
Da wird sich ja immer drüber aufgeregt
Und gesagt, boah, da gibt es auch diesen Witz hier
Also, klopf, klopf, wer ist da? Lange Pause. Hallo, hier ist Java.
Aber ich habe damit jetzt, sagen wir mal, noch nichts Performance-Kritisches gemacht, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja, Java ist ganz furchtbar lahm.
Und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass Java wirklich lahm ist.
Java ist vom Startup her vielleicht ein bisschen lahm, okay.
Aber der Rest ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, stimmt. Ein paar Sachen finde ich auch blöd, ja.
diese Gettazetter-Geschichte finde ich doof.
Auch was du hier schreibst.
Also, das sind
Auto-Properties aus C-Sharp.
Sind mir deutlich lieber, als
diese Gettazetter-Geschichte.
Na, also in .NET zum Beispiel
kann man einfach schreiben
hier
String, blub,
get, set.
So. Und das ist
quasi ein property mit getter und setter automatisch schon implementiert für ein
und noch besser mittlerweile seit der letzten c sharp version kann man sogar
einzelne sachen davon customizen man kann man kann dann zum beispiel könnte
dann zum beispiel hier sagen hier return blubb oder so ja das geht oder man
könnte sagen hier set
kann man hier sagen hier fehlt gleich value oder so also das ist da ist
vielleicht machen sie ja auch so was ist die frage ob man immer ein records für
alles und jeden verwenden will ja wenn man records verwendet braucht man das
nicht aber in normalen klassen brauchst du das also finde ich diese auto properties sind sie
schreibt schon ganz nice der rest ist aber vollkommen feinen java und ich muss auch sagen
spring boot fand ich mega nice spring boot fand ich sogar als jemand der schon recht viel in asp.
dotnet core gemacht hat und noch nicht viel in spring boot muss ich sagen von dem was es out of
the box mitbringt hat mir spring boot sogar von den features besser gefallen als asp.net core
hat es 100.000 annotations und so kann man sich darüber streiten aber was ich zum beispiel bei
spring boot extrem nice finde und bei quarkus auch dass sie zum beispiel ein messaging event system
oder wie man das nennen mag mitbringen ja du kannst hier in quarkus und spring
spring wird fast genauso aus kannst du zum beispiel sagen okay du hast hier
was was im hintergrund einmal die sekunde läuft und dann in jack dass da
einen emitter das ist das ist quasi so was wie den event bus in memory in jack
dass da eine emitter sagt hier einfach einmal in der sekunde im mitte ich hier
eine nachricht mit diesem inhalt und dann gehst du woanders hin und sagt ich
will jetzt alles was über diesen channel quasi published wird will ich haben und
dann wird automatisch diese methode hier aufgerufen und von da wird quasi klar
quasi diese message hier rein gepasst ohne dass irgendwas machen muss
sowas bringt asp.net core nicht mit man kann das selbst bauen man kann eines der
libraries verwenden dafür das ist keine frage aber dass sowas nicht eingebaut
das finde ich doof das finden das fand ich bei springboots sehr nice dass sie
sowas dabei haben und generell muss man sagen so die es ist eigentlich also bei
springboot quarkus habe ich ja so nicht so viel gemacht wird aber bei springboot
muss ich sagen es war jetzt nichts dabei wo ich gesagt hätte oh das fehlt aber
das ist schon mal ein gutes zeichen wenn du nicht schon bei der beispiel
anwendung feststellt ich würde gern das und das machen acht gibt es nicht
das habe ich bei vielen web framework schon oft gehabt ja in anderen sprachen
im goal ist es ganz schlimm teilweise von rasch war gar nicht an
Da kriege ich bei der Standard Library teilweise Anfälle.
Aber bei Spring Boot war echt alles dabei und bisher was ich von Quarkus gesehen habe,
war das auch echt durchdacht.
Zum Beispiel was ich mega nice finde in Quarkus, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen anders wie
in Spring Boot, ist das Handlen von Config.
Also wenn man seine Anwendung konfigurieren will, da sagt man in Quarkus, ich zeige euch
das jetzt mal da sagt man den qualen uns einfach hier guck mal ich definiere welche konflikt also
welche optionen ich haben möchte das hier interface das musst du nicht app konflikt
das habe ich so gern warum es ein interface sein muss keine klasse ich habe keine ahnung
es muss ein interface sein sagst du public interface app config als im brief fix ausdenken
und die folgen da sagst du hier ich will eine option haben die intervall heißt wenn um die
default value eine sekunde so und was das jetzt macht im hintergrund ist das guckt jetzt hast
du command line parameter gesetzt also sowas hier zum beispiel und ich glaube das kann man glaube
ich weglassen minus minus intervall gleich 5s guckt es ob du sowas angegeben hast das guckt
ob du zum beispiel sagst ob du in weimar und variablen gesetzt hast das guckt ob du application
properties gesetzt hast und letztendlich guckt darauf die europäische fall values gibt also in
dieser reihenfolge übrigens auch guckt das quasi alle stellen wo du config option angeben könnte
es durch für dich schon das musst du nicht selbst machen und map das dann hier rein also es ist dass
das hier reicht im endeffekt dass ich diesen wert hier setzen kann über command line argumente über
ein weinend variablen über einen config file oder halt aus den defaults holen wenn nichts gesetzt
ist mehr muss ich nicht machen da guckt also wenn ich jetzt hier sagt zum beispiel hier sieht man
es ja schon guck mal hier wird der default value eine sekunde gesetzt so wenn ich mir diese message
kriege ich auch per
diese Config Option
kriege ich hier per WebSocket geschickt.
Wenn ich jetzt mal abbreche, ja, und ich sage
hier Export
Intervall
keine Ahnung, 5 Sekunden
und starte
ich das. Jetzt ruft man
das nochmal ab.
Ja, auf
Das sind 5 Sekunden.
Ich habe nichts gemacht, außer eine Environment-Fache
abgesetzt. Also das Handling
von Konfiguration finde ich sehr nice.
Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Wenn man eine weitere Konfiguration-Option
haben will, also sagen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel
nicht Intervall, sondern noch
Verbose
oder so.
Ja.
Da ist Default-Value ist
False. Ah ne, das muss
vielleicht jetzt Buhl.
schon habe ich wieder die möglichkeit command line parameter zu setzen environment variablen
zu setzen konflikt datei zu setzen oder die verhalten auf default wenn es zurück zu greifen
das ist mega nice aber wenn man das verwenden will ist ganz easy man in jacks sich das einfach
app config also das handling von configuration finde ich sehr nice das geht in asp.net core
ähnlich.
Aber ich finde nicht ganz so elegant.
In Spring
ist das auch so ähnlich.
Aber das finde ich, das haben sie echt gut gemacht.
So, aber jetzt legen wir mal los.
Lass mal überlegen.
Also,
lass mal überlegen, was brauchen wir denn für...
nochmal jetzt gesagt,
das ist keine Anwendung, die irgendwas Sinnvolles
machen soll. Das ist einfach zum Üben.
wir bauen jetzt ein bisschen noch was bei den web sockets dran wir gucken dass wir
noch ein paar metriken einstellen und sowas und es generell einfach ein bisschen quarkus angucken
sondern lass uns mal überlegen was könnten wir denn für was brauchen wir noch für konflikt
optionen also boss ist schon mal okay genau wir machen da einfach wieder unsere übliche
metrik geschichte rein dann brauchen wir noch eine config option nennen wir das data dir die
ford ist data das wollen wir alles konfigurierbar machen und dann haben wir noch ihr process name
aus das name standardmäßig ist keine ahnung oder so haben wir unsere optionen so wo sind wir gestern
entstehen geblieben ich glaube gestern wollte ich das hier machen deswegen habe ich dann auch
ein to do reingeschrieben jetzt ist es ja aktuell so dass einmal pro sekunde wird diese methode hier
ausgeführt im hintergrund das macht quarkus für uns automatisch weil wir
dieses ad scheduled attribut annotation oben dran haben
übrigens ein bisschen blöd finde ich dass wir das gemacht haben an der stelle
warum muss das ein string sein warum gibt es kein heim punkt irgendwas oder
oder intervall punkt irgendwas
wahrscheinlich weil das konstante zur compile zeit sein muss deswegen nicht
das wird es wahrscheinlich sein
so jetzt ist die große preisfrage wie kriege ich das kaste meist
also ich will jetzt ja per konflikt option hier aus der config hier wo es aktuell eine sekunde
gesetzt ist wenn ich da fünf sekunden setze will ich dass der background task alle fünf sekunden
startet ist funzt ja so aber gar nicht weil das hier hardcode zur kompilzeit drin stehen muss
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt irgendwie so einen eigenen Scheduler starten.
Die Frage ist, wie machen wir das?
Okay, gucken wir mal in die Hilfe rein.
Scheduling Periodic.
ja also wie man das mit dem attribut macht das haben wir schon gesehen
dass das hammer das ist ja nichts neues
bla bla bla gibt es da nicht irgendwie so dass sie jetzt getue programm atyp
ok guck mal übrigens meine das hat ja denkt sie irgendwie kaputt
schädler programm da war doch was mit intervall in config
oder
mal zweimal hier
Ach so.
Äh.
Aber wie machen die das denn jetzt?
Ach so, man kann hier irgendwelche
Expressions
Ne, das gefällt mir nicht.
Ich will das programmatisch
programmatically
starten.
weil ich will ja dann auch andere Sachen hier dynamisch machen aus der Config.
Wir gucken mal wie man selbst den Scheduler startet.
Das hier.
Das ist alles nur mit Annotation.
Ah hier.
Varkos provides a build in Bean.
Das habe ich übrigens auch noch nicht gecheckt.
Was ist ein...
Was ist eine Bean?
Das lese ich bei Java ganz oft.
Ich habe kein Blast Scherz.
Ah, guck mal, man kann sich den Scheduler injecten.
Das klingt doch schon mal gut.
Aber ich will ja nichts pausen oder resumen.
Ich will ja irgendwas queuen da drauf.
Geht das auch?
Scheduling long running tasks.
Executing a long running task.
Das ist mein Yellow.
das wollen wir nicht programmatik scheduling da haben wir es doch
dass ich habe gestern wieder irgendwelches zeug gelegt
das heißt eine klasse die ich quasi mit aqua cross die pendels die injection registrieren ist dann
eine Bienen.
Aha, so geht das.
Also, wir müssen den Scheduler
injecten.
Machen wir mal. Hier.
Dann
machen wir das da weg.
Wir generaten
generate wir generierten einen konstruktor und dann machen wir das im kopf ja oder wird schon sagen
und dann sagen wir scheduler new job okay aber ich kopiere mir das mal kurz hier rüber
scheduler new job okay den job den nennen wir das passt mal auf jetzt habe ich mir
Ich habe mir Java Sachen abgeguckt.
Da sagen wir Punkt Class.
Punkt Get Name.
Jetzt heißt der Job wie meine Klasse.
Soll ja auch nur einmal gestartet werden.
Was es ja auch ist, weil Application scoped.
So, Set Cron.
Ich will es einmal pro Sekunde, beziehungsweise pro Intervall ausführen.
da bringt mir eine
Cron-Expression ehrlich gesagt nicht
sonderlich viel.
Gibt es nicht sowas wie Intervall oder sowas?
Set Delayed.
Set Delayed?
Was ist das?
Aha.
Ist das das, was ich haben will?
Oder Set Intervall?
ich glaube ich will es jetzt intervall haben so und das sagen wir jetzt konflikt
sag mal an die an die high iq java kenner hier aus dem chat
ich habe jetzt ja hier so eine klassen variable wie nennt man das ding instanz variable klassen
Feld, sondern Feld in der Klasse.
Genau, Feld ist das Richtige.
Wenn ich da jetzt
drauf zugreifen will, kann ich
ja einfach hier reinschreiben.
Aber
da sieht man jetzt ja nicht so,
also wenn ich da drauf referenzieren will,
da sehe ich jetzt ja anhand
der Sache nicht,
wenn es jetzt ein bisschen längere Methode ist,
dass das hier keine lokale Variable
ist, sondern ein Feld aus der Klasse
in
In C Sharp wird das auf zwei Sachen gelöst.
Man schreibt Dista vor, das geht in Java auch.
Das ist das, was Microsoft eine Weile empfohlen hat.
Aber es hat sich im C Sharp Umfeld etabliert,
dass man Klassen, so Felder in der Klasse,
die kriegen einen anderen, also Private Felder in der Klasse,
kriegen einen Underscore.
Und dann hat man so geschrieben.
Da erkennt dann quasi jeder,
ey, das ist keine Variable hier aus der Methode raus,
sondern aus der Klasse.
So, wie macht man das in Java?
Was ich jetzt schon gehört habe, ist, dass diese Geschichte mit Underscore davor total verpönt ist.
Ist halt die Frage, wie macht man es in Java?
Schreibt man dann Dis davor?
Aber dann müsstest du ja gefühlt laufend Dis schreiben.
Oder scheißt man da in Java einfach drauf und sagt, ja gut, man wird schon rausfinden, wo es herkommt.
Post? Oh, jetzt wird's...
Der Auskennfuchs ist wieder am Start.
Moin, lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Pog?
Ähm...
Der Auskennfuchs ist der richtige CSS-Pro hier.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Der kann euch den Unterschied zwischen Flexbox und Grid erklären.
Ist schon wieder abgekackt, die Musik?
Nee.
Also, ich würde den Schedule eine extra Funktion mit PostConstruct Annotation initialisieren.
Ah, ob die Injects im Constructor schon aufgelöst sind.
Ach so.
Das heißt, ich mache PostConstruct.
Post Construct ist quasi nachdem die Klasse erstellt wird, wird das nochmal aufgerufen.
Ich könnte aber auch einfach Constructor injecten.
Aber Post, Post, das finde ich, okay, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Quarkus, Post Construct.
Lifecycle Callbacks.
Post Construct Init.
Okay.
Das heißt sowas hier.
Ist vielleicht auch besser, weil dann kann die Klasse beim Constructen nicht failen.
Machen wir das mal so, dass da aus kein Fuchs schreibt.
Also.
So dann, oder? Und dann schreiben wir davor Post Construct.
das war aber private ich hoffe man das dürfen private machen bei den ersten jahren mäßig
private was sind denn methoden standardmäßigen jahre sie protected wenn nichts davor steht was
ist die was ist der default breit oder protected package private also quasi
alles im gleichen modul oder wie
und das hier muss übrigens auch nicht okay dann starten wir das dann starten
wir das da drin ach übrigens auskennen fuchs jetzt wo du gerade da bist demnächst machen
wir wieder frontend zeug wird mal wieder zeit ich müsste ja auch am start so also lasst uns
mal hier weiter gucken jetzt haben wir gesagt intervall ist quasi das aus der config so aktuell
5 Sekunden.
Und jetzt
stelle ich hier einfach
ein, was ich ausführen will.
Ich will alle 5 Sekunden
im Endeffekt Update
ausführen.
Kann ich nicht Update hier
aufrufen?
Dass ich so sage, Update?
Ne, das funktioniert
natürlich nicht.
ESP gebastelt.
müssen wir auch wieder machen.
Da kann ich mich vor allem über C++ aufregen.
Und übrigens, Leute, wisst ihr, wo wir
demnächst mal, zumindest auf die erste halbe Stunde
reacten müssen? Eines der
besten Videos, die ich dieses Jahr gesehen
habe.
Wie hieß denn dieses Video?
Das da.
C++, C++.
Pass mal auf, das fängt schon gut an.
Wir gucken das jetzt nicht.
Ich sag nur, das Video ist echt gut.
C++ ist absolut atrocious.
Zuerst einmal, es gibt so 20 verschiedene Wege, eine Variable zu initialisieren.
Und es gibt so viele Regeln und Edge-Fälle, die man initialisieren kann,
dass jemand ein 300-Page-Textbuch nur auf dieses eine Thema geschrieben hat.
Das was wir dann nächst gucken.
Zwei Stunden.
Aber wir gucken nicht
zwei Stunden komplett.
Wir gucken nur die erste halbe Stunde.
Danach wird's...
Wobei, das ganze Video ist gut.
Und was ich cool finde,
dass tatsächlich
vieles der Sachen, die er anspricht,
exakt die Dinge sind, die ich auch kacke finde
an C++. Das wirst du dann demnächst
gucken.
Ups, falsch.
Wie, das wäre als wäre für mich gemacht, das Video, oder?
So, also, weiter im Text.
Ähm, wie kann ich denn jetzt hier unten auf diese Methode verweisen?
Update alleine tut's ja nicht.
ähm
gute Frage
ach muss ich vielleicht irgendwie sagen
Backgrounds
Background Updater
Updates
macht man das in Java?
Ich will nicht die Methode aufrufen, ich will da quasi drauf zeigen.
Das geht bestimmt irgendwie so, ich weiß noch nicht, wie die richtige Sonntags ist.
Ich mach kurz gucken.
Was? Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt?
Ah!
Moment, Chat, ich lese gleich die Message.
Was hat er jetzt?
Oh, IntelliJ ist mal wieder abgekackt.
Non-static method cannot be referenced from a static context.
Static?
Was ist hier an Static?
Moment.
Das Funds doch auch.
Hier ist nichts Static.
Laber nicht, Java, Alter.
Ach, kann das sein, dass die Fehlermeldung einfach nur Shit ist?
Und ich hier...
...als die passende Parameter brauche?
Nee.
Okay, Leute, ich habe keinen plastischen Schimmer.
Keine Ahnung, warum das sich futzt.
Dann ist egal.
Egal. Macht nix.
Anders hat's ja gefunzt.
Ist schon merkwürdig, oder?
Ja.
Das ist Doppelpunkt, Doppelpunkt.
Aha.
Fuck.
Okay, auf die Syntax wäre ich im Leben nicht gekommen, Leute.
Und jetzt ist wahrscheinlich...
Jawoll!
Es funzt.
Okay, da wäre ich jetzt wirklich ohne euch nicht drauf gekommen, auf die Syntax.
Also jetzt schedulen wir einmal pro Intervall diesen Task und emiten Kekkel in unseren Websocket.
Okay, das sollte jeder so machen. Prinzipiell sollte die Default-Nachricht bei allen Log-Meldungen
kek-w oder kekkel sein. Dann darf man den restlichen Kram locken. Ich glaube,
das baue ich auf der Arbeit auch ein. Alle Logs kriegen erstmal so einen Kekkel als Prefix.
Man könnte sich ja auch überlegen
Ob man die Log-Level nicht in Twitch-Emotes
Umbenennt
Also
Lull ist quasi Info
Lull W
Ist Warning
Oder irgendwie sowas
Error gleich Failfish
Ja
Twitch-driven
Chat-driven
Programming.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt,
was ich hier gebaut habe.
Ich sollte jetzt
alle
alle fünf Sekunden
eine Nachricht kriegen.
Aber das scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Kann das sein,
dass das hier nicht aufgerufen wird?
Loggen wir mal.
Log.
Info.
Null.
Das wird nicht aufgerufen.
Warum wird Post Construct nicht aufgerufen?
Hä?
Wird nicht automatisch aufgerufen
Aber ich hatte doch eben diesen Background Updater laufen
Und das hat doch funktioniert
Moment
das muss ich jetzt
ach so
ich verstehe
ich jetzt habe ich es verstanden
was du meinst
gibt es da nicht irgendeine Annotation für
ich habe da glaube ich
irgendwas
so eine
Quarkus
warte mal
Startup Annotation oder sowas?
Hier, add Startup.
Das da wollen wir haben.
Add Startup.
Zack.
Pass mal auf, jetzt geht's. Easy.
Oh, was hat er denn?
Error.
Fail to start.
Warum?
Was ist das Problem?
Ist das Problem vielleicht mein...
Ich teste mal kurz, ob das hier mein Problem ist.
Ja, okay, ich mache es mal kurz weg.
Okay, das scheint das Problem zu sein.
Ähm, was genau?
Moment.
Jason, ich muss mal das Logging von Jason wieder normal umstellen.
GitHub.
Wie hat man das nochmal ausgeschaltet hier?
Markus, log Jason.
Ich will gar kein...
ich will gar kein jason logging machen im web
marcus log jason konsolen ebelt hier so kann man das ausschalten
ich brauche ordentliche ordentliche log meldung und erkenne ich hier nichts
Also, was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen, wenn ich das Ding da drinne?
Wenn ich hier das, wenn ich das schedule, was will?
Also, das funzt noch.
Ne, das ist, funzt schon nicht.
Guck doch, ob ist irgendwas abgekackt.
Oder hier, Error.
Was hat er denn?
Ne, das ist noch, Moment, das ist noch vom alten.
Ne, der lockt immer noch.
Der lockt immer noch.
Der lockt immer noch in Jason.
Aber was will er denn hier?
Ich hab gedacht, ich hab das Jason-Logging ausgeschaltet.
True.
Anscheinend war das nicht genug,
das hier auf False zu schalten.
Aber was hat er denn hier für Schmerzen
mit dem...
Kann das irgendjemand entziffern?
Startup-Action.
Alter, ich kann das nicht lesen.
Wie mache ich denn dieses dumme
JSON-Logging aus?
hab ich doch eben gelesen
jetzt kein jayce logging mehr
Ah, jetzt kann man es ordentlich lesen.
Also, was will er? Das hier mag er nicht.
Scheduler.
Failed to start Quarkus.
Caused by...
Scheduler was not started.
Aha.
Dann gucken wir doch nochmal rein, was der hier sagt.
Programmatic Scheduling.
Da steht nichts dazu da.
Ach, guck mal hier.
By default the scheduler is not started unless a scheduled method is found.
Quarkus Scheduler Start Mode Forced müssen wir machen.
Aha.
So.
Geht das jetzt?
Ah.
Es geht.
Und jetzt müsste alle 5 Sekunden.
Alle 5 Sekunden kommt jetzt eine Nachricht.
Und wenn ich jetzt einstelle.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Export.
Alle Sekunde.
Sehen wir gleich.
Ich bin mir noch nicht klar, ob die Konfiguration funktioniert.
Jetzt ist einmal pro Sekunde.
Seht, es funktioniert.
Und natürlich auch beste Log-Meldung überhaupt.
Nice.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Dann können wir jetzt weitermachen.
Also wir haben jetzt selbst einen
Background-Job
gescheduled.
Der dynamisch
aus der Config
sich das Intervall holt.
Ich meine, man kann es jetzt nicht zur Laufzeit
anpassen, das ist aber auch nicht notwendig.
Einmal beim Startup.
So, eigentlich ganz gut.
So.
Gut, dann bauen wir jetzt mal was Sinnvolles ein.
Und zwar, das ist jetzt ein bisschen weit hergeholt, aber das kommt aus einem praktischen Beispiel bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Also das ist jetzt nichts, was diese Anwendung können muss, was wir da jetzt einbauen müssen.
Aber zum Üben bietet sich das an.
Und zwar, wir haben auf der Arbeit eine Anwendung, wenn die anfängt ganz viele Pagefalls zu haben.
Also ein Pagefall ist zum Beispiel, wenn er irgendwas aus dem Speicher lesen will und das ist nicht mehr im RAM, sondern mittlerweile auf der Disk oder sowas.
Dann gibt es ein Pagefall.
Dann muss er das erst von der Disk laden.
Und wenn die Anwendung anfängt, ganz viele Pagefalls zu haben, dann hat die meistens Probleme und muss neu gestartet werden.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt mal. Wir lesen jetzt mal von irgendeinem Prozess Pagefalls aus, hier im Background,
schreiben das in eine Prometheus-Metrik und pushen die dann per Websocket an unser Frontend.
oder einfach nur die prozess abteilen oder irgendwie sowas
so jetzt ist die große preisfrage wie lese ich mit java sowas wie major page falls aus
für den prozess java major page falls gibt es da so was gibt es so was wie ich frage jetzt ich
frage mir fragen okay ich habe ich habe die idee wir machen jetzt mal mal gucken was was besser
ist ich frage mal mein lokales model wie man das machen würde und mal gucken
mal gucken was chat gpt dazu sagt wir können auch was anderes ausprobieren was
ihr wollt ja irgendwas wo man nicht registriert sein muss also ich schreibe
mal auf deutsch wir probieren wir beide sind deutsch ich will mit java die major page falls
von von einem prozess auslesen wie mache ich das unter linux unter linux auslesen
die macht auch geht eigentlich copy paste mittlerweile wieder meine vm ja gott sei dank
äh
Quen-Coder
wird geloadet
okay
fangen wir mal an
das braucht einmal
am Anfang ein bisschen
ach das Model ist nämlich noch gar nicht richtig geladen
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt. Wir müssen kurz warten, bis das Model geladen ist.
So, also, um die Major Page Falls eines Prozesses und Entliegungsmedia auszulesen, gibt es mehrere Ansätze.
Da Java keine direkte, native API zur Abfrage von Systeminformationen mit Pagefall bietet, musst du entweder auf Native Bibliotheken oder Systemkommandos zurück.
Ja, ich benutze irgendeine fertige Library, würde ich sagen.
Der einfachste Weg ist es, die Datei
Brock Pitstat zu lesen
In der sich unter anderem auch die Anzahl der Major
Page Falls befindet
Ja, das würde ich aber gerne vermeiden
Wollen, manuell Brock File System
Zu parsen, ehrlich gesagt
Ne, ne, ne, ne, PS und Top
Und so will ich auch nicht ausführen
Wenn nur einer performant oder detaillierte Lösung
Kannst du auch um C-Code
Nein, nein, nein, nein, okay
Gibt es
fertige Java
Libraries?
Mal gucken, ob das meine
Rechtschreibung korrigieren kann.
Ähm, die das können.
Oshii!
Oshii kann das.
Okay, halluziniert das oder gibt's das
wirklich?
Was meint ihr, Chat? Gibt's das?
Gibt's Oshii?
Gibt es, tatsächlich.
Native Operating System and Hardware Information.
Oshii.
Oshii.o-o-o.
Wenn ich die Domain sehen würde, würde ich denken, die wollen mich scammen.
Linux ist super, sagt ja.
Nächstes, Linux ist super.
Nächstes Jahr ist das Jahr des Linux-Desktops, Leute.
Ich sag's euch.
Was ist denn die OOO Top-Level?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ist...
Das müssen wir mal nachgucken.
OOO TLD.
Eignet sich besonders gut für Musiker.
Was? Warum?
Sie steht für
Out of the ordinary
Wirklich? Oder reimt sich die
AI das jetzt zusammen?
Wir sind näher dran
Als jemals zuvor an dem Jahr des Linux-Desktops
Das stimmt
Das kann ich so unterschreiben
Microsoft sind die einzigen
Die Windows zerstören können
Und da sind sie ja gut dabei gerade
Was ist da?
Oh, oh, oh, Domain.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das hört sich fast
ho, ho, ho wie bei Weihnachten an.
InfiBeam.
Hab ich nie gehört.
Aha. Siehste?
Lernt man nicht aus. Also.
Oshi brauchen wir als
GitHub.
wir fragen jetzt mal zum vergleich wir fragen jetzt mal chat gpt was das dazu
sagt also chat gpt wir können auch wir können auch ein dac ai fragen oder oder
oder perplexe die kommen wir müssen jetzt mal nicht übertreiben
also ich will mit java die menschen falls vor einem prozessor wie mache ich
das
Aha.
Drei praktikable, linux-typische Wege,
die man aus Java nutzen kann.
Proc, Pit. Ne, das will ich nicht.
Das will ich nicht.
Das ist mein lokales Model,
ist deutlich schneller.
Alternative, Pit. Ne, ne, ne.
Das will ich auch nicht.
Für den eigenen Prozess, wenn du nur
die Page folgst, dann ist ja...
Nein, brauche ich nicht.
also so richtig richtig geil ist die antwort von chat gibt ja auch nicht
und fragen wir die dann fragen wir mal hier gibt es fertige java libraries die das können
ja mit einschränken es gibt keine reine java standard library die major
politiker es gibt aber etablierte die über brock oder native calls bereits
fertig implementiert sind. Oshii.
Okay. Also Oshii scheint
beliebt zu sein.
Dann benutzen wir Oshii.
Okay, komm.
Wir fragen DuckDuckAI noch.
Was für ein Model wollen wir denn benutzen?
GPT5 Mini.
Ne, das andere
geht ja nicht.
Da muss man sich ja einloggen.
Ey, komm, genug AI-Spiele rein.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wie Oshie funktioniert.
Oshie.
Es geht ja schon damit los, dass ich wieder zu blöd bin,
zu checken, wie man das bei Maven jetzt einbindet.
Downloads und Dependency Management, Stable Version.
Oshie Core?
Was?
stable release version jdk 8 jp ms frankfurter main
was möchten die mir mit diesen 1000 abkürzungen sagen also das in alte version würde ich mal
behaupten also ich denke mal ich brauche das ich weiß zwar nicht wofür ffm steht aber das
steht java 25 drin und java 25 habe ich
das hier braucht man die pendency aus meine pomm xml hier ist meine pomm xml
tag xml reload weiß auch nicht warum war was das mit frankfurter main zu tun hat
aber offensichtlich hat das ja irgendwas mit frankfurt zu tun
frankfurt goethe straße louis vuitton store zahl die kollektion bar fick auf
sponsor
so was doch wie von stars jetzt gibt es da examples vielleicht sammelt
examples
was unten war noch was zu 25
aha new module or she core java 25 er steht doch hier ist noch available haben wir es
doch das haben wir doch hier der module intent zu provide api kompatibel using
es wird schon funktionieren
import system info ffm instead of system info
ok gucken wir mal
findet man schon mal nett
geil
top
ah ne import
ok import
irgendwie
kann das sein dass mein
java das nicht so richtig gecheckt hat
dass das
sich was neues installiert habe.
Ich sehe auch noch mal
Maven hier neues Zeug runterladen.
Oshie.
Hä?
verarscht auto komplett findet es nicht aber wenn ich okay also was soll man
system info ffm und dann wie von stars denn jetzt ich muss mal hier ein beispiel
angucken also der process process suchen wir mal
print pro spin processes das ist gut hier genau wo es jetzt process und wo kriege ich jetzt und
Wo kriege ich jetzt
OS her?
OS?
Aha.
Okay.
System-Info.
Also, okay, gut.
Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Also, ich brauche irgendwie sowas.
System-New wahrscheinlich.
New System-Info.
Wir können das ja auch importieren.
Import Oschi.
Systeminfo.
Get.
Operating System.
und jetzt processes aha geht processes okay dann machen wir das doch mal dann
würde ich sagen wir initialisieren uns das hier oben
ja das machen wir und das war auch hier drinnen
Weil das brauchen wir ja global dann.
Das machen wir in einem Konstruktor.
Macht doch Sinn.
Was wird das hier drinnen anlegen und dann sagen hier OS oder irgendwie sowas in der
Richtung.
Und das System Info da irgendwie oben reinschreiben.
So, create field system info.
So, machen wir.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Kann nicht gelesen werden oder so.
Ja, ist mir doch egal.
Ne, was will er denn? Kann...
Oh, jetzt ist es schon wieder kaputt, IntelliJ.
Sauerei.
Ist...
But never exist.
Ja, das kommt dann schon noch.
Okay.
So, das heißt, wir können jetzt hier in unserem Scheduler
sagen...
This
System Info
Get Operating System
Processes
Und da machen wir eine Schleife drüber.
Process
Okay
Und nun
müssen wir hier mal ein paar Sachen rausfiltern.
Wir printen.
Leute, wir printen das jetzt einfach nochmal hier.
Process.
Get Name. Einfach nur gucken,
ob es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Und es sollte einmal pro Sekunde
ausgeführt werden.
Ja, klappt auch. Guck mal hier.
Fast schon
H-Top.
Okay, da gibt einmal pro Sekunde
alle Prozesse aus.
Das ist gut.
So, jetzt suchen wir hier nach einem Prozess drin.
Nämlich, was wir hier in unsere App-Config über Bash haben wir da reingeschrieben.
Was wir über unsere Config reinkriegen.
Von diesem Prozess wollen wir die Major Page Falls uns auslesen.
Also, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
das war irgendwie
if
process
Punkt
oder noch
noch
if
process get name
is
ah ne Moment, das von 10 Jahr war nicht
equals
check bei strings auch genau checkt ob das die gleiche instanz ist das funst nicht da
brauche ich was anderes da brauche ich replace objekt equals genau
ob checkt eagles process get name und jetzt ab konflikt
process name.
Warum ist das ein Buhl? Das soll kein Buhl sein.
Das soll ein String sein.
Nein, ich habe noch kein Battlefield 6 gespielt.
So, und wenn das...
Moment.
Moment, ich muss noch kurz nachdenken.
Da machen wir eine eigene Methode draus.
Hier, machen wir irgendwie sowas hier.
Was ist das hier für ein Typ?
OS-Process.
Get-Process-Info oder sowas.
String-Name.
Dann machen wir das nämlich hier drinnen.
Hack.
Return-Process.
ansonsten
grow
new
io exception
process not
found
name
oh ne
darf ich nicht
weil
method signature
Das macht doch an der Stelle Sinn, eine Exception zu schmalen, weil wir können ja nicht wirklich irgendwas damit anfangen, wenn es keine Process-Info gibt.
Also holen wir uns mal hier, Process gleich, jetzt Process-Info, App-Config, Process-Name.
So.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Unhandled Exception.
Ja gut, da können wir das surrounden mit einem Try-Catch-Block.
Und das loggen wir dann einfach als Error.
Gut ist.
Aber wir brechen nicht ab.
Dementsprechend gibt es noch Fatal.
Ja okay, dann loggen wir tatsächlich ein Error.
Sonst hätte ich es nur als Warning geloggt.
Battlefield 6 macht keinen Spaß
langfristig, warum nicht?
Ich bin immer noch nicht sicher, ob ich
nicht doch anfangen soll
Ich bin skeptisch
ob es sich jetzt noch lohnt
aber ich glaube, ich werde es
ich habe es ja sogar gekauft, ich werde es mir angucken
ich habe sogar einen Rechner neu installiert
dafür, dass ich spielen kann.
So, jetzt haben wir hier die Prozesse.
So, jetzt können wir gucken.
Wenn wir den Prozess haben, können wir sagen,
Process, get
Major Falls.
Das will ich haben. Genau das.
wir locken einfach mal wir locken mal ein paar sachen von diesem prozess also sagen wir lockt
info war das dann sagen wir jetzt hier new process info values und dann muss man sagen kv oder so
oder auch nicht wie war das noch mal genau keine info sondern hier können wir jetzt hier drin
können wir etwas loggen ach so das lockt ja gar nicht auf standard aus ja egal dann machen wir
mal wieder machen wir wieder jason jason logging an sagen hier jetzt ich hoffe ich hoffe dass
funktioniert was ich jetzt hier ausgehen will sagen wir machen wir mal zeit map of gut und
jetzt gehen wir mal hier sagt also process eine idee haut hier den kompletten bildschirm
voll so process get name geben einfach mal ein paar sachen davon aus so als nächstes geben wir
mal die keine abheim gibt so was ab time wir gehen einfach mal ein paar sachen für den prozess aus
ist auch nicht verkehrt process process pitt process id ok so und dann die major falls
prozess match falls und dann meiner falls das reicht jetzt jetzt meiner falls ok dann
war mal gucken ob das moment was da los was ist da los
ah ich bin ich bin doof guck mal moment was das name ist doch richtig data die
sollte bis an zu bringen sein was was was was haben wir für schmerzen
alter java lies was ist dein problem jetzt okay ich komme das mal aus dass
Gut.
Was hast du für Schmerzen?
Request has already been...
Äh, jetzt geht's.
Der würde...
Also, so wie ich es machen würde, ist...
Der würde den Jason Logger
in Prot verwenden,
Aber jetzt, während ich entwickle, also im Prinzip sowas, wie ich es hier gemacht habe eigentlich, den ordentlichen Output, dass ich auch was erkenne.
Aber ich will halt gerade mal checken, ob der auch das Richtige lockt.
Und irgendwie...
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was der für Probleme hat.
Der kommt mir diese Map oft nicht klar, hä?
Der hat Probleme mit meinem...
Mit dem Kram, was ich logge.
Der kommt hiermit nicht klar.
Pass mal auf, jetzt geht's.
Warte mal, jetzt tut's.
Hä?
Ach, ich hab...
Hab ich das Import vergessen?
Ach, ich hab den Scheduler aus...
Oh.
Hä?
Okay, ich hab...
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Ich bin...
Ich bin grad einfach zu blöd gewesen.
Okay.
jetzt mal gucken ob es jetzt wieder funktioniert okay okay es von alles alles gut ich habe nicht
an was hat er denn da das ist die die fehlermeldung gewesen dass das geld oder nicht gestartet ist
ach so aber guck mal als funs der lockt hier info pit mit falls ab time prozess und major falls 0
sehr gut sehr gut das war nur der erste prozess vielleicht sollten wir überlegen wir mal vielleicht
machen wir es auch so dass man mehrere prozesse haben kann weil best läuft ja mehrfach so dass
aber jetzt schon mal rausgekriegt um jetzt brauchen wir jetzt müssen wir da irgendeine
Prometheus-Metrik draus machen.
Oder wir schicken sie erstmal per Websocket
an
ans Frontend.
Ja, egal, das machen wir jetzt.
Mal gucken, wie man das
per Websocket jetzt schicken würde.
Also.
Wir brauchen
auf jeden Fall
ein Message-Format,
weil ich muss jetzt ja quasi von
diesem Background-Thread
das über meine Message-Queue
schicken,
zu meinem Websocket-Händler
hier hin.
Das heißt, wir brauchen irgendein
Websocket-Message oder sowas.
Also, machen wir das mal.
Probieren wir das mal aus hier.
Public, Record,
Websocket,
Message
und
brauchen einen Record
Klammer auf, Klammer zu, ja.
muss in der eigenen datei ich weiß so string was moment was was kriegt der gut der krieg
eine message wir übertreiben es jetzt ja mal nicht ja kommt er kriegt gar nichts der kriegt
einfach nur in abteilung kriegt nur die abteilung geschickt ist es ja einfach nur zum ausprobieren
Ich will ja nicht wirklich damit irgendwas machen.
So, WebSocketMessage.
Jetzt sagen wir hier New.
WebSocketMessage.
Und jetzt einfach nur hier Process.Uptime.
Äh, achso.
Ha, vielleicht sollte ich das hier noch in dem Block drinnen machen.
Uptime.
Funzt nicht. Warum?
Ah, in Long muss es sein.
Okay.
Was ist in Long?
In Int64 oder was?
Ist das in Int64?
Oder ist Long Long
in Int64?
Long ist in Int64.
Naja.
man lernt so oder so jetzt muss ich auch angeben welche message typ verwendet werden soll und das
ist websocket message vielleicht nicht die beste benahmung okay das funst dann gehen wir mal unseren
Websocket-Händler rein
und sagen hier,
dass wir jetzt eine
Websocket-Message bekommen.
Und die senden wir.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Easy!
haben wir unsere Uptime.
WebSocket.
Dann würde ich sagen,
dann stellen wir die jetzt mal auf der Webseite da.
Möglichst hässlich.
Ja, www.index.html
Okay, Leute.
WebSocket in JavaScript from scratch.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal?
also
LED, Websocket
Verbindung, New,
Websocket,
genau,
Local,
oh, guck mal hier, das denkt ja voll mit
8080,
slash, WS,
musst du mir jetzt noch sowas machen,
wie Connect,
ne, ne, äh,
On Message,
On Message.
Okay.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
So?
Nee, oder?
Oder doch?
Ist das richtig?
Macht man so?
Nee, oder?
Okay, probieren wir mal aus
Argument is not assignable
Okay, nee, nee, nee, das funktioniert
nicht.
Ach nee, so war das. So war das
doch, gell? So ist das.
Das ist doch JavaScript. Moment, so war das doch.
So,
Log. Nee, Moment.
Console.log
e.data
Jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt, ob das Funst, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Lass uns mal kurz hier hingehen.
Konsole aufmachen.
Easy.
Geht.
wir haben unsere Uptime im Browser
im Browser
dann schreiben wir die Uptime jetzt hier unten drunter
nochmal
ID gleich Uptime
Millisekunden
ich hoffe mal das sind Millisekunden
ja das sind Millisekunden
und das heißt
jetzt sagen wir hier
javascript wie war das document get element bei id ab time
und jetzt inner html inner text gleich e.data
mal gespannt haha ach so ja gut vielleicht nicht das ganze sondern jason punkt pass und dann
so
reactives frontend leute
über websocket die abteilung von von der best
macht überhaupt keinen sinn aber darum geht es ja auch nicht
messe frontend
Und jetzt kommt mir bitte keiner mit, Max, du musst das zentrieren und irgendwie mit einer Flexbox, dass es dann schön...
Das muss nicht schön sein.
Wobei, zentrieren könnten wir es wirklich, oder?
Das machen wir.
Komm, das ist eine einzige Frontend-Geschichte, die machen wir.
Wir zentrieren es.
Mal gucken, ob ich das überhaupt hinkriege, mit Flexbox was zu zentrieren aus dem Kopf.
ähm, Display,
Flex,
das alleine reicht nicht, ne?
Ähm,
Flex,
Direction,
Column,
dann ist es untereinander,
und jetzt muss man sagen,
Justify, oder irgendwie sowas,
Items, Justify,
allein allein allein content center das war's nicht was was just if i just if i content center
ach shit auch nicht wie zentriert man was was allein items vielleicht center
justify items center ach scheiße man
wie wie ich es noch mal das ist der alte klassiker passiert es haus center diff
center
Wieso ist doch... Guck mal hier
Hab ich doch gemacht
Das hab ich doch eben schon
Ach nee
Ah, Moment
Man braucht... Aha
Man braucht...
Align Item Center, Justify Content Center
geht aber nicht
ich weiß ich bin ja auch ich bin ja auch viel zu dumm ich bin ja auch viel
zu dumm das kann ja noch nicht funktioniert was
hier gemacht habe passt überhaupt nicht totaler blödsinn weil ich hier gemacht habe ich habe das
in das ja schon schon ist gesendet da war jetzt hier noch ein diff drum ich habe misst ich habe
mist gemacht das hat das hat schon gestimmt was ich am anfang gebaut habe style gleich mit wechseln
ja leute es ist cent hat rege rege so seite ist perfekt so kann die für immer bleiben das ist die
schönste seite ever easy clap jetzt haben wir gesendet unser akademisches hütchen hier und
die abteilen von unserer bash genau das unbedingt das hat da hat die welt drauf gewartet auf diese
seite okay gut immerhin das funst schon mal mit web sockets wir loggen richtig schön viel krebs
raus ist auch gut kann man später dann irgendeinem lok analyse tool ordentlich auswerten weil es jason
Logging ist.
Okay.
Dann würde ich mal sagen, weiter im Text.
Weiter im Text.
Wir machen da jetzt eine Prometheus-Metrik
draus, weil das muss man ja auch gucken,
wie man so anwendungen ordentlich monitoren kann das habe ich mir in spring gut schon angeguckt wie
das funktioniert aber keine ahnung wie man das in quarkus macht war kurs prometheus mit mikrometer
matrix genau so heißt der kram was muss ich denn überhaupt in klugen dafür mikrometer registry
Prometheus muss ich includen.
Mach ich. Bam.
Der lädt wieder das halbe Internet runter
und bam, kaputt.
Warum?
Unable to execute Mojo.
Aha.
Okay, es funzt aber trotzdem.
Was auch immer.
Manchmal muss man der Sache nicht folgen können.
Also, wie machen wir das?
Wie machen wir das jetzt?
Zeig mal her.
Metal Registry. Nee.
Create your own
Metrics. Das will ich haben.
Okay, Registry.
Wir müssen das mal kurz...
Wie ruft man das jetzt eigentlich ab?
Curl? Localhosts?
Slash
Blub oder Slash Metrics? Ach, hier, guck mal.
slash kuhs lesch mit tricks okay man kriegt hier eine ganze eine ganze menge
metriken für prometheus schon raus die die fall für die java anwendung sind ok
ich will aber eigene metriken hinzufügen wie geht das jetzt meter
registry
ok wir in jacken die registry jose global meter registriert das ist mir sogar noch lieber global
reds registrieren die in jacken wir uns auch hier die müssen uns nicht checken
Ach komm, hier.
War das einfach so.
Takt, inject, bam.
Metaregistry.
So, und nun?
Können wir das sagen?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Wie fandst du das jetzt?
Collection Size Registry.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt mal so, wie ich das noch von Spring Boot kenne.
Das ist ja weder Spring Boot noch Quarkus eigentlich. Das ist diese Mikrometer Library.
Das ging. Also was ich jetzt machen will ist, ich will alle Prozesse, die ihr hier findet,
will ich jeweils
eine Metrik exportieren
für diesen Prozess
mit
keine Ahnung,
Uptime oder so.
Nur zum Testen.
Das heißt, ich brauche Labels,
weil ansonsten kann es ja jeden Prozess
nur einmal geben. Das will ich ja nicht.
Das heißt, es muss ein Prozess sein
mit einer PID und einem Name
dabei, dass das eindeutig ist.
Übrigens, ich habe ganz vergessen, hier war es in den Chat.
Ich wollte doch vorhin den Chat lesen.
Da hat doch jemand geschrieben.
Moment, Moment.
Irgendjemand hat doch vorhin was richtig langes geschrieben.
Bin ich jetzt plö...
Ah, hier.
MarziLine hat geschrieben.
das wollte ich eigentlich noch lesen
Marcylein bist du noch da?
ich hab das voll verpeilt
Marcylein hat vorhin irgendwas geschrieben
hier
wir haben bei der Arbeit eine selbstprogrammierte
Software auf
Python Basis
Python
die Messdaten aufbereitet
mit DB, Web, Oberfläche und so weiter
weißt du ob Dienstleister
die sowas reviewen was taugen?
ne, keine Ahnung
oder was ist eine gute möglichkeit code reviewen zu lassen ja am besten von
leuten also wenn du es programmiert hast nicht von dir selber also ich würde das
intern handhaben also was man machen kann wenn ihr beispielsweise intern
keine ahnung geht lab oder so verwendet da kannst du automatisch reviewer
einstellen lassen für jeden merge request die nicht derjenige sind der den
Merch-Requeste aufgemacht hat.
Trägst einfach
das gesamte Team ein
und es wird erst gemerged, wenn es einer
reviewed hat.
Okay, aber so wie ich das jetzt sehe, ist das ja schon eine
bestehende Anwendung.
Da kann ich dir nichts zu sagen.
Ihr könnt das doch selbst reviewen.
Ist natürlich schwierig,
wenn man,
wenn du es selbst komplett gebaut hast
und
das auch reviewen sollst.
Aber du bist ja
wahrscheinlich nicht der Einzige im Team.
Ansonsten mit Dienstleistern,
die das reviewen, ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer.
Ich sagte, ich arbeite auch nicht hauptberuflich in der Softwareentwicklung.
Keine Ahnung.
Das kann passieren.
Oder du hast so überpingelige Leute.
Manchmal, ganz ehrlich, Fehler werden sich nie vermeiden lassen.
Manchmal muss es einfach schnell gehen.
Manchmal steht auch irgendwie einer dahinter, dein Chef oder noch der Abteilungsleiter,
und sagt, wir müssen jetzt ganz schnell.
wenn die dann auch am Ende die Verantwortung
dafür übernehmen, ist das ja okay.
Manchmal muss es
schnell gehen oder manchmal kann man nicht.
Manchmal muss man so
eine Abzweigung nehmen.
Setzer,
ob ich das morgen machen,
morgen Nachmittag muss ich nochmal nach
Frankfurt fahren.
Vielleicht, vielleicht danach.
Aber ich wollte jetzt ja Metriken anlegen.
curl matrix kreppen wir mal meine matrix werden irgendwas mit process heißen also
prozess gibt schon jede menge dann rock rock anders heißt meine matrix okay gibt's nicht
sehr gut watch minus n alle 0,1 sekunden abfragen gut wie legen wir jetzt hier eine
Metrik an. Also im Init können wir sagen registry gouch und dann ein Number angeben. Also probieren
wir das mal. Name, proc, uptime. Einfach nur mal testweise. 1. Easy, Funst, Metrik ist da. So,
kann ich diese metrik jetzt auch updaten beispielsweise hier drin einmal pro
sekunde 2
subscription to default has been cancelled was container not initialize
ist der container startet ich glaube das zeigt einfach nur mist an gerade oder
wenn ich lasse es noch mal noch mal starten
warning
ach guck mal hier oben ist eine meldung ist gott hat ihn gar nicht oder wie auch
immer es bin already registered ja das konnte das ging aber das habe ich das
das habe ich mit mit swing gut schon mal gebaut da gab es so einen fleck da
konnte man sagen hier auf oride oder so aber das gibt es hier anscheinend
anscheinend nicht
aber hier gibt es ein callback oder irgendwie sowas was ausgeführt wird
aber das ist ganz schön umständlich
wenn ich das das ist ja eklig ich könnte jetzt ich könnte jetzt hier
sowas machen hier zum beispiel keine ahnung 1 so wie viel will ich jetzt ja
so und da kann ich jetzt returnen und wenn das ist ja war so muss man das
machen
ich frag das voll ab dass intelligenz so oft kaputt gehen in letzter zeit und
man keine pop-ups mehr gehen ist already die feinden
so das müsst jetzt das müsst jetzt aber das funktioniert auch weil es ja auch
schon already registered ist das heißt ich müsste das hier oben machen im innet
und dann hier irgendwie das in den feld schreiben und dann hier auslesen
boni das ist ja super abartig zumal ich ja dynamisch sachen hinzufügen will und
und und und löschen so nennen das muss das kann man so nicht machen
dann machen wir das so wie das wie ich den spring wie ich den spring gut
gemacht habe das müsste hier auch funzen weil mikrometer ist ja die
Library unten drunter. Also,
da konnte man sowas sagen hier wie, äh,
oh shit, ähm,
Metas?
Nee, ähm,
Matrix?
Matrix,
war das so?
Ja, genau.
Go, nee.
Mult, Multi,
Multigouch, nee, äh.
Moment, lass mich mal kurz nachgucken.
ich hab das hier irgendwo bei mir lokal im
Git
Ah
Aha
So ging das
So, dann machen wir das hier oben, so ging das
Also hier, Multigouge
Bilder
So, und da kann man jetzt sagen
sowas wie hier
Prog-Uptime oder so.
914,
danke für den Sub.
Pog.
Huge Subscription.
So, und da
jetzt sowas wie...
Was hab ich hier gemacht? Base Unit?
Base Unit.
Was ist ein Uptime?
Milliseconds oder sowas.
hier Milliseconds
und nun
genau
Register
Register, so
genau, so und da
machen wir das mal
brechen wir das mal um
und das kann ich jetzt hier
oben
das kann ich in eine Variable
schreiben, nennen wir das mal
hier
Up-Time-Metric.
Create Field.
Komm, das machen wir auch
im...
hier oben.
Guck mal, es ist schon wieder kaputt.
Guck mal, IntelliJ ist schon wieder kaputt.
es kommt kein pop-up wenn ich hier drüber hafere wenn ich das hier zu machen wieder öffne geht
das ist das also das ist in letzter zeit ist habe ich das gefühl die qualität der jetbrains sachen
lässt nach also wie sieht es bei euch aus verwendet doch bestimmt auch irgendwelche
irgendwelche JetBrains-Produkte, oder?
Sei es jetzt Goland, Rider,
ähm,
IntelliJ, PyCharm.
Habt ihr auch den Eindruck, so die letzten 1-2 Jahre,
dass die Qualität ein bisschen nachlässt?
Es ist nicht schlimm. Also, ich kann das immer noch
gut benutzen. Mir ist das immer noch lieber wie
Visual Studio oder sowas.
Aber, ja, VS Code benutze ich
auch, aber VS Code benutze ich nur für Frontend-Zeug.
Ich benutze beispielsweise
keinen WebStorm, das mag ich nicht.
mir kommt so vor als haben die jetbrains leute die letzten 12 jahren bisher nachgelassen und
das highlight haben ja gestern gesehen flieht wird ein wird eingestellt für irgendwelche
dinger auf der anderen seite das fliegt nichts wird war abzusehen
warum habe ich eigentlich so viel cpu auslastung ich mache doch gar nichts
Achso doch, ganz viele Requests.
Okay und jetzt kommt 5-Head-Time.
Jetzt muss ich folgendes machen, passt mal auf.
Das ist jetzt 6-Head.
Jetzt muss man sagen, wenn man hier neue Werte hinzufügen will zu dieser Metrik.
Jetzt muss man sagen, Up-Time-Metrik.
Punkt.
Jetzt nochmal Register.
Ganz wild. Ich schreibe das jetzt auch ab.
Nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich weiß das jetzt aus dem Kopf.
Wir haben eine richtige IDE-Inflation.
Haben wir?
Es ploppen ganz viele neue
AI-Editors auf, ja.
Aber
wie geht's?
Gescheite?
Gibt's da so viel Neues?
ich habe letztens gesehen es gibt eine neue dort net idee dies auf gut oder gut heißt
ja glaube auf einer game engine basis fürs juli schlecht so also register so und jetzt passt
mal auf jetzt geht es so list of multi
gefragt mich nicht warum man das so
machen muss das schreibe ich jetzt
einfach nur ab aus was andere was schon
mal gebaut haben
da kann man jetzt die tags angeben
moment so einfach ist es auch nicht
tags
auf
Monka ist all der wenn sich das ausgedacht hat so
Ja keine ahnung
Prozess
Kriegt ihr prozess geht nehmen
Wir könnten das jetzt habe ich was jetzt habe irgendwas verkehrt gemacht
Wir könnten das übrigens noch mal umbrechen vielleicht dann
Schmerzen
Was hat er jetzt?
Ach so.
Und jetzt muss man hier noch die...
Moment, da sind mir zu viele Klammern.
Leute, zu viele Klammern.
Äh, wo sind wir hier?
Okay.
Da muss jetzt noch ein Value hin.
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Jetzt funzt noch nicht mal das, was ich hier...
Ich meine, ich habe das nicht mit Prozess-Uptime, aber...
Alter, warum ist das so eklig gemacht?
egal ich schreibe ich schreibe noch mal kurz weiter ab okay vielleicht vielleicht geht es
ja dann jetzt muss man hier jetzt muss wir hinten sagen true hier kommt die number hin moment
ihr kommt hin
Okay
Funden Sie es jetzt?
Was für eine Abartung
So legt man Prometheus-Metriken an
Mit Multimeter
und überschreibt sie jedes Mal.
Und jetzt muss ich, irgendwo muss ich noch
Irgendwo konnte man jetzt noch angeben
Könnte das hier gewesen sein, dass man noch sagen muss
True? Ja! Override True!
Ich hab's hingekriegt!
Easy! Es ist nicht so einfach
Easy, es ist komplett
Obvious, wie das funktioniert.
Wer das nicht
sofort erkennt, dass man das so schreiben muss.
Kachnub, Alter.
Liegt auf der Hand.
Cannot invoke.
Oh, nee.
Nee.
This registry ist
null?
Ah.
Die registry ist null.
Weil.
Im Konstruktor, das noch nicht drin ist.
Ne.
Hier die Registry.
Die ist null.
Kann ich nicht sagen. Moment.
Wir machen jetzt einfach hier.
Wir injecten das hier.
Das reicht doch.
Aha!
Es funzt! Guck mal!
Process Uptime Millisekunden.
Process Bash.
Und das ist die Uptime in Millisekunden.
In wissenschaftlicher Annotation.
Trivial ist das.
Komplett trivial.
Und wir brauchen noch einen Tag.
Noch einen weiteren Tag.
Prozess reicht nämlich nicht.
Wir brauchen auch noch
nicht Prozess, sondern
Name. Wir brauchen auch noch die
PID.
Prozess, get.
ID.
GetProcessID.
Achso, gibt es sowas wie
toString? Ne.
Ne.
Moment
String, wie ging das
String, Value of
Value of, ne
Genau, ha, guck mal Leute
Langsam sitzt die Java-Geschichte
5-Head-Time.
So.
Da sind wir. Guck.
Name Bash Pit.
So. Und jetzt
sind wir mal noch
5-Headiger.
Ich sagte mal,
das kann man doch viel schöner machen hier, oder?
Kann ich nicht sagen. Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Nochmal Java-Stells.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
System Info, Get Operating System,
Get Processes
und jetzt Stream,
Filter,
ja, keine Ahnung, Process,
P
und jetzt hier drinnen
mal einfach
sagen,
was da?
So,
Guck mal, da kann ich mir doch die Schleife sparen, oder?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Result is ignored.
Ja, ja.
Das ist doch schöner als die Schleife, oder?
So.
Und jetzt sagen wir einfach, if...
Oh, irgendwas ist aber noch nicht richtig.
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Habe ich in der Klammer nicht zugemacht?
Ah, ich habe in der Klammer nicht zugemacht.
Äh, to list.
Und jetzt kann ich doch sagen, if processes count oder sowas.
Length.
Count.
E.
Nein, es muss doch.
Ach, ist empty.
Okay, ist empty.
Ist empty.
Dann werfen wir eine Exception.
Process not found.
Ansonsten returnen wir
Processes.
Oh.
Äh.
Ja. So ist doch gut.
Jetzt kriegen wir alle Prozesse zurückgeliefert.
Äh, gut.
das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
doof.
Processes.
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal hier den ersten.
Process gleich.
Gibt es noch die First?
Ich wähle ja nicht die Klammern bei ein If.
Solange es nur ein einzeiliges If ist,
darf man die Klammern weglassen.
Gibt es sowas wie First?
Get First. Ja, genau. So machen wir das.
Woher kommt das Wissen?
Ich kann ein paar Programmiersprachen, aber nicht gut Java.
Aber Java kann man sich viel von C Sharp und anderen Sprachen ableiten, wenn man die schon gesehen hat.
Ansonsten bin ich der übelste Kack-Noob.
Guck dir nicht zu viel ab.
So. Aber...
jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich ja hier mit allen prozessen drin die also mit
allen prozessen drin das heißt ich kann jetzt darüber lupen
und eigentlich müsste ich übrigens das hier in der schleife gleich machen ich
bin da ich doof processes warum will ich das immer mit cc schreiben echt ihr
mögt das nicht, ich finde, ja eigentlich hast du recht, eigentlich hast du recht.
Process, so das muss jetzt hier rein, in die Schleife, das ganze gelogge und das hier muss
da auch rein und jetzt sollten wir gleich wenn das alles richtig funzt reformat jetzt
sollten wir für jeden bash prozess was
Ah!
Ja gut.
Das ist jetzt natürlich
nicht so richtig, aber
Oh, Bash gibt es nur einmal?
Wirklich?
Och nee.
Ähm, Moment.
Gibt es irgendwelche Prozesse,
die mehrfach laufen?
Grab Bash
Bash läuft noch mindestens zweimal
Läuft es zweimal?
Ja, ne?
Gibt es auch zweimal
Hier
Process
mit der Pit
und mit der Pit
Warum gibt es denn aber nur eine Matrix?
Nee, nee, es ist schon...
Warum gibt es denn die Matrix dann nur einmal?
Ach so!
Oh!
Man darf das nicht mehrfach anlegen
mit unterschiedlichen...
Man muss das alles hier drin irgendwie anlegen.
Oh, da bin ich jetzt aber zu nubig für.
Hier, in diese List of muss das rein.
List of?
Versteht ihr mich?
Also man darf das nicht mehr ver...
Hier, das muss...
Die ganzen Werte müssen da reingeschrieben werden.
Okay, also können wir das nicht mit der Schleife hier machen?
Boah, das wird jetzt aber vielleicht ein bisschen...
...iglich.
Okay, das ist das Letzte, was wir machen, Leute.
In fünf Minuten gehe ich was essen.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir das in 5 Minuten hinkriegen.
Wir müssen also List of Multigou...
Ach du Scheiße, Mann.
Hier.
Wir brauchen eine Multigouge Row.
Also, okay, okay, okay.
Probieren wir das mal.
Process.
Stream.
Map.
Ich hoffe, das ist Map.
Process.
So, und aus diesem Process bauen wir jetzt...
Lull.
Wirklichsbesseres ein.
Aus diesem Process bauen wir jetzt uns diesen Shit hier zusammen.
Also, return.
So.
Also.
In Lull.
Lull ist jetzt.
Eins.
Two.
Malen wir noch hier.
Two list.
0 ist jetzt eine Liste aus Row Numbers.
Okay, okay, das passt.
Dann iteraten wir mal jetzt über 0 anstatt über...
Okay, das muss ich will jetzt einfach mal was bauen was funktioniert okay, danach können wir uns das schön machen so
Und jetzt brauche ich gar keine schleife mehr jetzt kann ich einfach das hier nehmen
Raus raus ziehen wir das mit lassen wir fort und sagt jetzt im endeffekt list of
list of lul oder warum nicht man intelligent wieder kaputt
9 sofern exist so was was will das vor
jetzt bin ich zu dumm dafür was hat er was hat er für probleme
No instances of type variables exist so that row number conforms to row Fragezeiten.
Was?
What?
Lull ist schon eine Liste?
Ah, richtig, richtig.
Ha, und schon geht's.
Schon geht's?
Okay, funzt es jetzt?
BÄM! Unser komisches Gefrickel hat funktioniert!
Wir haben jetzt für jeden Bash-Prozess eine eigene Metrik mit Uptime.
IZ! IZ!
Moin!
Completely Trivial!
So, jetzt sollten wir das vielleicht nicht Lull nennen.
Sondern...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was für einen Namen für dieses komische Konstrukt, was wir hier haben.
Rose.
Rose, okay?
ja gut weiß das gefällt mir dass das ist also so schlecht ist das gar nicht
das war jetzt für jeden prozess eine eigene metrik sondern können wir jetzt
nämlich dem auch noch mehr metriken geben
können jetzt zum beispiel noch eine metrik das ist wirklich jetzt letzte was
wir jetzt machen wir können zum beispiel sagen wir wollen
noch eine metrik dass das war weiß ich eigentlich ursprünglich machen will
major wie habe ich den kram genannt
MajorFaultMetric.
CreateField.
Warum willst du das eigentlich immer da oben anlegen?
IntelliJ. Und nicht
hier unten, wo das andere Zeug
auch ist.
BaseUnit ist
auf jeden Fall
nicht Uptime, sondern
Pagefalls sind in...
Das ist einfach ein Counter, oder?
Events.
Bytes.
Percent.
Messages.
Objects.
Rows.
Sessions.
Tasks.
Threads.
Äh.
Es ist einfach nur eine...
Nur eine Anzahl...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Dann sagen wir einfach
Pound.
Okay.
So, und jetzt
können wir uns da schnappen.
Ach, Moment, muss ich das jetzt nochmal
anlegen hier?
Nochmal Rose?
Das muss ich in der Funktion auslagern.
Das wird sonst deutlich
zu eklig, weil das müsste ich jetzt nochmal
machen hier. Dann machen
wir das das nächste Mal.
Ich muss jetzt was essen. Essen ist nämlich auch schon fertig.
Chat.
Ich weiß, ich habe zu einer
sehr ungünstigen Zeit heute gestreamt.
Trotzdem nice, dass so viele dabei
gewesen sind. Ihr könnt ja auf Follow drücken, wenn ihr
das nächste Mal mit dabei sein wollt. Ich habe mich übrigens das letzte Mal
sehr gefreut, dass so viele Leute
Leute
reingefollowt haben.
Sehr nice.
dann machen wir noch ein Quarkus-Stream.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich nur einen machen.
Dann sind wir nicht fertig geworden.
Dann haben wir zwei.
Und jetzt sind wir nicht fertig geworden.
Dann machen wir noch drei.
Wir machen also einen Quarkus-Stream.
Dann würde ich sagen,
haben wir genug Quarkus gelernt.
Oder vielleicht auch noch einen vierten.
Ich weiß nicht.
Je nachdem, wie wir fertig werden
und ob ihr wollt oder nicht.
Man kann ja drüber gucken.
Aber schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Der Stream bleibt heute auch online,
weil ich habe nichts geleakt und denkt an den follow wenn ihr das nächste mal
wieder mit am start sein wollt oder am start wieder fabian früher der fraser
früher immer gesagt hat am start am start start ist kann das nicht
aussprechen sowie schacht schacht schacht spiegelt mich im chat auf
Jetzt vorbei.
Max in der Peking-Suppe.
Max in der Peking-Suppe liegt.
Dieses Video hat mal irgendeiner gemacht
vor zwölf Jahren, Alter.
Oh ja.
Okay, Leute.
Wir sehen uns dann.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.